los insurgentes talibanes logran
ocuparse en el poder por primera vez en
1996 en 1998 ya controlaban el 90% del
territorio su nombre proviene de la
palabra thalif estudiante el grupo
atrajo originalmente a radicalizados
muyaidines o combatientes por la yihad
afganos y extranjeros que con
financiación estadounidense lucharon
contra las tropas soviéticas hasta su
retirada en 1989 los fundamentalistas
liderados entonces por el mulá mohammad
omar basaron su agenda en la
interpretación rigorista de la ley
sharía introduciendo castigos físicos la
pena capital- erradicando cualquier la
expresión cultural y despojando las
mujeres de todos sus derechos pero
también se nutrieron de la influencia
tribal pastún desde la frontera
afgano-paquistaní donde comienzan a
agruparse en 1994 su poder no se
entiende sin el apoyo de pakistán desde
su nacimiento talibán se alimentó de la
ideología suní de pakistán y es en el
vecino país donde se refugiaron sus
líderes tras su caída en 2001 con la
invasión de eeuu como respuesta a los
atentados del 11-s puesto que el grupo
protegió osama bin laden jefe de al
qaeda mientras planeaba los ataques
terroristas durante 20 años de invasión
el talibán permaneció a la sombra en
territorio vecino planeando la campaña
insurgente para recuperar el poder en
afganistán en febrero de 2020 eeuu y los
islamistas firmaron un histórico acuerdo
que establecía el calendario para la
retirada de las tropas extranjeras del
territorio mientras impulsaba un diálogo
con el gobierno afgano para poner fin a
la guerra civil sin embargo después de
años de un conflicto desgastado y sin
atención mediática el fin de las
operaciones internacionales en 2014 el
grupo talibán reafirmó su célebre frase
vosotros tenéis los relojes nosotros
tenemos el tiempo veinte años más tarde
la bandera blanca del autodenominado
emirato ondea en el palacio presidencial
de kabul